you
professor Alex abrikosov and Tony
Leggett what are the sources of
inspiration to you as a scientist doctor
like it I think that's rather difficult
question to answer actually I think in a
scientific discovery luck plays an
enormous role but I think one thing one
can be fairly sure about is that if
you've not been thinking about the
problem continuously and perhaps even in
your when you're lying awake at night
for some time to have some weeks or even
some months and it's unlikely that
you'll get the sudden flash of discovery
isn't that makes it work and what would
you say doctor because my my answer for
me the inspiration was always experiment
some experimental facts which were
strange could not get an immediate
explanation and so on these were always
my source of inspiration and I think
that only that yes I am very closely
connected to experiment not mathematics
not models not input but experimental
data and and and so of course after that
what Tony said the thinking and and so
and even sleepless nights that is of
course it comes how as a part of
scientist yes however my ideas I just
bring come take from experiments